perhaps the best way to measure the
impact of a pandemic is to look at how
many more people are dying there might
usually be expected at this time of year
what we call excess deaths these include
people not officially diagnosed with
Kover 19:00 and those who died
indirectly for example have a heart
attack but don't go to A&E now Sky News
has analyzed the latest data on European
country since the start of the outbreak
on the 2nd of March to the 12th of April
from Euro Momo the network that collects
it it uses an algorithm to compare
countries and the gray area here shows
the average level in a normal year the
UK has split into its constituent
nations the blue line flashing here is
England and as you can see along with
Italy and Spain England has the highest
levels of excess deaths so far 18 points
above the overall average it reached
this in the week ending the 3rd of April
the week after Italy and Spain but as
you can see England was the only country
to continue that trend into the
following week the week it's thought the
UK peaked in fact if we just look at the
UK's Four Nations we also see that
England's excess deaths in the last few
weeks have been far higher than those in
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland up
here in total since Europe's outbreak
began around 57 thousand more people
than expected have died in the 24
countries studied that's an increase of
18 percent almost 53,000 of those deaths
are among people aged over 65 which is
20% higher than usual but even younger
age groups those aged between 15 and 64
recorded more deaths than normal around
6000 in total up almost 14 percent with
countries recording their covert 19
deaths differently this data is really
valuable it gives us a clearer picture
than we've had yet of how many extra
deaths the virus could be causing